the fbi warns that the critical daily
functions of hospitals are at an
increased risk of being hacked and in
tonight's cyber safe parent we look at
what needs to be done to keep patients
safe
hospitals and health care organizations
are a vulnerable target for a cyber
attack lagging behind other industries
in cyber readiness
the fbi has warned of an increased and
imminent cyber crime threat to u.s
hospitals metro lieutenant alan larson
with the health care sector we have seen
a huge increase in the amount of attacks
that are targeting our health care
partners we've even had some local
hospitals and clinics here in clark
county that have been you know victims
of cyber attacks a worrisome aspect is
that critical health care components
from ct scans to medical devices to the
refrigerators that store blood for
surgery could be compromised what would
be the very worst case scenario is if
they were able to compromise in such a
way that they're able to shut off power
or shut down their systems you know
they're providing this critical care to
these patients that would be the most
devastating thing electronic health care
record systems are now the norm for
private patient information if that gets
compromised now you can re-victimize
those patients lieutenant larson
encourages cloud-based servers to keep a
layer of separation from on-premise
servers endpoint protection for
computers attached to company networks
and firewalls requiring double
verification for patient portal records
we also have a healthcare working group
where we work with the information
security officers from these different
health cares
hospitals things like that to be able to
give them pointers and tips on how they
can help increase their infrastructure
so that they don't become victims of you
know a cyber attack experts warn the
time is now for a shift in the thinking
and planning of hospital cyber defense
with a far greater value being placed on
cyber security in the health care sector
it's of the utmost importance
now you can find all of our previous
segments many with helpful cyber hygiene
tips for businesses and individuals over
on our website eightnewsnow.com under
cyber safe parent